- Hello everybody, welcome.
I'm Alice Kaplan, director of
the Whitney Humanities Center
and professor of French and
Francophone studies at Yale.
Welcome to this webinar,
celebrating the reissue this summer
of William Gardner Smith's
1963 novel "The Stone Face."
I'm grateful to the
Whitney, to the Yale Center
for the Study of Race, Indigeneity,
and Transnational Migration,
and the Department
of French and Francophone
Studies for their support.
We'll be looking at a novel that has been
out of print for so many years
as issues at its center,
racism, police violence
and war and memory have taken center stage
in both France and the U.S.
I'd like to briefly introduce
our three panelists.
Each of them an important
voice on these issues.
Adam Schatz is a contributing
editor at "The London Review
of Books" and a contributor to
"The New York Times Magazine"
"The New York Review of
Books" and "The New Yorker."
He is one of the very keenest analysts
of Algerian politics and literature
whether he's writing about
Kamel Daoud's fiction
or the legacy of French
torture in the Algerian war.
Adam last visited Yale in 2019
to lecture on Franz Fanon.
His 2019 "New Yorker" article,
"How Does It Feel to be a White Man?"
William Gardner Smith's Exile,
was important in bringing "The Stone Face"
to public attention, but
most important of all,
Adam has written the introduction
to the forthcoming "New
York Review Books" edition
of "The Stone Face."
Tyler Stovall is a French
historian whose work
on the red belt suburbs of Paris,
on the history of racism
in France, on post-colonial
and transnational history
have defined a field.
I'll mention just two of his many books.
"Paris Noir: African Americans
in the City of Light"
where I first learned
about "The Stone Face"
and his newest, "White
Freedom, the Racial History
of an Idea" where he
explores the centrality
of white racial identity to
an understanding of freedom.
He has served as Dean of the
Humanities at UC Santa Cruz
and as president of the
American Historical Association.
He is currently Dean
of the Graduate School of
Arts and Sciences at Fordham.
Lia Brozgal is associate professor
of French and Francophone studies
in the Department of European Language
and Transcultural Studies
at the University of
California Los Angeles.
Her book, "Absent the
Archive: Cultural Traces
of a Massacre in Paris, 17 October 1961"
just published by
Liverpool University Press,
maps through a series of
brilliant cultural analyses.
The afterlife of the October
17 massacres of Algerians
in Paris, a state crime that
was censored officially,
but that survived through the work
of artists and writers
like William Gardner Smith.
Lia has lectured at Yale
on the representation
of October 17 and she was
a much appreciated speaker
in my war and memory seminar this fall.
So here's how we're structuring the hour.
First, introductory remarks
to set up our conversation.
Adam Schatz will talk about
William Gardner Smith.
Tyler Stovall will discuss Paris Noir
and the black expatriate literary scene.
Then Lia Brozgal will talk
about the October 17 massacre
and its representation in "The
Stone Face" and other works.
After these introductory
remarks we'll go into dialogue
leaving 10 or 15 minutes at
the end for audience questions.
So please feel free to submit questions
throughout the hour in the Q and A panel,
and check the chat where
we'll be posting references
to works mentioned wherever possible.
So Adam, I'll pass the floor to you now.
- Thank you so much, Alice
for that warm and generous introduction.
It's a pleasure to be here.
Speaking with Tyler
Stovall and Lia Brozgal,
two historians I admire a great deal.
I first became aware of
William Gardner Smith's novel
"The Stone Face," which
was published in 1963,
about a decade or so ago
via a friend of mine,
a scholar at Columbia,
Brent Hayes Edwards,
who has written extensively
on the literature of the black diaspora.
And then I began to come
upon references to Gardner Smith's work in
Tyler Stovall's magnificent
history of black expatriates
in Paris, Paris Noir, and
in the work of Kristin Ross.
And I ordered a copy of the
book because I was intrigued.
And in fact, astonished by the fact
that the first fictional depiction
of the October 17th, 1961
massacre of Algerian protesters
by the Paris police had been written
by a black American expatriate novelist.
In the introduction to this book
I described Gardner Smith
as a long-forgotten novelist
but in order to be a forgotten,
you have to have been remembered.
And I don't think,
and Gardner Smith was always
a very obscure figure.
So I became very curious
about who Gardner Smith was.
He was born in 1927 in Philadelphia.
He grew up in a poor neighborhood
of black Philadelphia.
And by the time he was in his teens
he had experienced terrible
beatings by the police.
He became a journalist at
a very young age, at 17.
He was hired by the Pittsburgh Courier,
one of the most important black newspapers
in America and not long after, he ended
up going to Germany with
the American military.
He served there just after the war
for about eight months and on
his return at the age of 22
he published a striking novel
called "Last of the Conquerors."
Was published by Farrar,
Straus and Giroux.
And it's about a black soldier
in Germany who paradoxically finds freedom
for the first time in the
arms of a white German woman
in a country that had just
recently slaughtered millions
of people on racial grounds.
And when I read this book,
which is a very lyrical account
of a romance and also
a devastating treatment
of racism in the American army,
it struck me that Gardner
Smith was someone who was
at one in the same time
very interested in issues
of social justice and racism
and at the same time attracted
to complexity and difficulty.
And one of his great preoccupations
was the question of belonging,
which is at the center of
his novel of "The Stone Face"
about a young black American
journalist Simeon Brown
30 years of age, who comes to Paris.
And at first, experiences as
a kind of paradise and falls
into the soft embrace of
the black expatriate scene
at the Cafe du Tournon
around writers, inspired
by figures like Richard
Wright and Chester Himes,
Richard Gibson, but then
Simeon Brown realizes
that in fact, there are
people who are treated much
like black Americans were back home,
and they were Algerians.
Neither black nor white.
And he's drawn into the
Algerian liberation struggle.
And he arrives in 1960 and a year later
he witnesses the October 17 massacre.
James Baldwin in his
essay on Richard Wright,
published just after Wright's death,
"Alas Poor Richard" lamented
that Wright had become
complacent about French racism.
He had begun to enjoy what it was
like to be a white man in Paris.
I think it was somewhat unfair of Baldwin.
In fact, Richard Wright did
write about French racism
but this, in this essay, Baldwin reflects
on what he calls the
hazards of expatriation.
He never wrote that novel,
although he did comment
on the problem in some of his essays.
Gardner Smith is the one
who wrote that novel.
And it's, has a very
French theme the same time
because the theme is fraternity.
What defines brotherhood and what we find
in "The Stone Face" is
that it is not skin color.
It is not race.
It is ethical action.
It is solidarity.
And in the case of Simeon
Brown, it means disaffiliating
from other black expatriates
and joining up with Algerians.
It's a rather bitter account
of the black expatriate scene,
not what we're really accustomed to.
So now I'm going to turn the table over,
turn the floor over to
Tyler Stovall, who is really
our leading expert on
black expatriates in Paris.
Thank you very much.
- Thank you, Adam.
And thank you Alice for
this wonderful introduction
and for organizing this event
and thank you to the
Whitney Center at Yale.
I just want to follow up a bit
on a few of the things Adam said
about "The Stone Face"
and William Gardner Smith
and put it into a broader
historical context
of the whole history of African-Americans
in Paris in the 20th century.
This is a community that, I
mean, had long antecedents
but really began to take
shape as a defined community
in the years after the First World War.
The First World War had
brought the first mass presence
of African-Americans, some 200,000
to France in the American army.
And almost all of them
of course, went back home
but a few stayed, and
African-Americans stayed partly
because they had introduced jazz to France
and they were able to use
it as a way of surviving,
in fact prospering in the
country during the 1920s,
during les années folles.
And it's when they
first began to develop a
geographical community in the neighborhood
of Montmartre, in Northern Paris.
So this is a community that, by the 1930s,
and certainly by the 1940s
had a real sense of itself.
And it developed a sense
of itself as blithe,
creating a role in a
front in a foreign nation
that was very hospitable,
very enthusiastic
about African-American culture in contrast
to the situation of African-Americans
in the United States.
So thus began what I've called
the myth of colorblind Paris.
The idea that Paris was
the city free of racism,
and that in particular, Paris
was a city that welcomed
with open arms African-Americans.
After the Second World War
this community renewed
itself, it had disappeared
during the war itself.
All the African-Americans
had left virtually
but many came back after
the Second World War
and they re-installed the community.
This time it was more of a
literary community headed
up by Richard Wright, excuse me.
And this is the community
that William Gardner Smith
joined in 1960.
So, and it was a very
fascinating community.
William Gardner Smith
found himself in the heart
of what was in many ways, the
heart of black intelligentsia
and certainly the heart
of the black literary world
in the 1950s and the 1960s.
And yet William Gardner
Smith also represents
a broader turning point in this,
the life of this community,
if you will, the sort
of decline of the idea of
France as a colorblind nation
because if he comes to France at a time
of great welcoming of
African-Americans, he also comes
to France in the middle
of the Algerian War,
France's great anti-colonial struggle.
And it's worth reminding
people that France was involved
in anti-colonial wars from basically 1946
when it began the war to
repress the Vietnamese struggle
for independence, until 1962.
So this was a major
theme in French history
and it is William Gardner Smith
that brings an awareness of
this aspect of French life
which includes an awareness
of French racism to the eyes
of African-Americans and
to Americans in general.
So he is the one that more
than anybody else really
calls into question,
and ultimately destroys, the
myth of colorblind France,
points out that France
in many ways has its own kinds of racism,
just as much as the United States does,
and is very explicitly drawn
to an assessment of this.
He is also the one that who
in doing so really draws together
two of the great movements
for justice of the post-war
world, the movement
for civil rights in the
United States and the movement
for decolonization in
Africa and Asia and Europe.
These two movements
have a lot in common and
"The Stone Face" is one that
makes that commonality explicit
by exploring the ways in
which an African-American
would see himself drawn
to anti-colonial struggles
and see them as part of his own struggle.
The classic statement,
"how does it feel to be a white man?"
really is very complex
because it basically
is forms William Gardner
Smith's way of saying
that race is positional.
It is not an absolute,
but race and racism
depend on time and place.
And one can be racially
excluded in one context
and very much a part of
the racial superstructure
and part of the racial
hierarchy in another context.
And so it's a fascinating novel that looks
at the ways in which racism is defined
both in the United States and in France.
And then there's the whole issue
of his portrayal of the October
17th, 1961 demonstration.
When I first lived in France,
it was some 40 years ago.
And I remember reading
"Libération" on October 17th, 1981
the 20th anniversary of the demonstration.
"Libération" had a big
three page spread about it.
And it was portrayed
on terms that emphasize
over and over again, how virtually nobody
in France even knew that
this history existed.
And I found that to be true,
when I asked people I met and
nobody had ever heard of it.
And some people said Libération was lying
and it did not actually exist.
So this demonstration forms
a fascinating plot device
in "The Stone Face."
It really brings together
William Gardner Smith's arguments
about racism, Algeria,
and the United States
but it was also of course
a real historical event.
And the fact that it occurred,
and the fact that he
was able to integrate it
into his novel, showed just how important
not just this incident,
but the whole relationship
between American racism
against African-Americans,
and French racism against Algerians
between decolonization,
the civil rights struggle,
how important that relationship was
and how determinate it
was of the 20th century,
mid 20th century, as a whole.
So I want to now pass the
floor onto a professor
Lia Brozgal who's going to talk a bit more
about October 17th.
- Thank you, Tyler,
for that perfect segue.
I came to "The Stone Face"
through my work on the
cultural representations
of the October 17th police massacre
of Algerian demonstrators.
So I'm going to make a couple
of points about how this
episode is represented
in William Gardner Smith's novel,
but also try to offer
some broader information
about how literature, film,
and other cultural texts have
stepped in to fill the void
in knowledge surrounding October 17th.
As Tyler just mentioned, even in 1981
the general discourse in
France regarding this event was
that nobody knew, or nobody had seen,
or that the event itself
had somehow been invisible.
Despite the fact that it took place
in the center of Paris
on a Tuesday evening.
So there are three texts that belong
to what I've called the sort
of first wave of cultural
representation of October 17th.
That is three cultural
texts that attempt to
represent October 17th in
the immediate aftermath
of the heat of the action.
The first cultural text, if you
will, is a documentary film,
an hour long documentary film
called (speaking French),
October in Paris by an amateur filmmaker
named Jacques Panijel.
The second is a poem
written by Kateb Yasine,
who is often considered the
doyen of Algerian letters.
The poem was written in French
and it's called in
French, (speaking French)
which is best translated into English
as "In the Jaws of the Wolf."
And both of these, both the documentary
and the poem focus wholly on October 17th.
"The Stone Face", however,
is the only fictional work
from this time period of the early 1960s.
And the premise of the novel
interesting is not
ostensibly October 17th,
and indeed within the novel, October 17th,
the massacre that took
place on October 17th, 1961,
it doesn't really take up that much space.
It represents less than 10 pages of prose
in a novel that's slightly
over 200 pages long.
And yet the slenderness of this chapter
I think belies the
significance of October 17th,
historically for the
protagonist Simeon Brown
of "The Stone Face" and
in terms of the cultural
production of October 17th.
So historically I'd just like to point
out that October 17th,
wasn't just any protest
and really can't be swept aside
as just another bump
in the turbulent decade
that was the Algerian war.
This was really a significant episode
of state sponsored violence.
It stands to this day
as the deadliest episode
of colonial violence to take
place on metropolitan soil.
And it remains the bloodiest day
in Paris since World War II.
Now, interestingly, some of our
some of our listeners
might recall headlines
following the terror attacks
that took place in November
November, 2015 in Paris, often
the headlines after that day
consecrated it as the deadliest day
in Paris since World War II.
And in fact, that can only be true
if you sort of bracket off October 17th.
And this is interesting insofar
as it really embodies the
ways in which this day and the
the violence of October 17th
has kind of been bracketed
within the French historical record.
So the novel, "The Stone Face" comes
to its dramatic conclusion
with the events of October 17th
making it really the
paroxysm of this novel.
And despite having been
warned not to get involved
with the events, our
protagonist Simeon goes out
into Paris that night, and
he witnesses in central Paris
firsthand thousands of Algerian protesters
some 20,000 Algerian protestors processing
through iconic Parisian
neighborhoods and boulevards.
And then he witnesses the brutality
of the police repression
and indeed the conditions
of detention as Simeon himself steps
in to try and protect an Algerian woman
who's being beaten by a
Parisian police officer
as she tries to protect her
infant son from the blows.
And so Simeon in fact,
experiences October 17th
as both a witness to the violence and
in certain ways as a kind of
victim of the violence as well.
He's beaten by the police
before he's a summarily thrown
into a paddy wagon and
taken to a holding center,
a sports stadium that had been converted
into a temporary holding
center for Algerians
and where he spends the night
witnessing the conditions of
of the Algerians in prison
and then finds himself
released from the stadium,
due once again to the type of
odd privilege he's experienced
throughout the novel, that is
as being considered privileged
and powerful as compared to the Algerians.
And so in a way, we also see
that the October 17th is a catalyst
for his own political thinking,
his own soul searching
the soul searching he's been engaged with
throughout the novel.
Soul searching about race
and racism, his place
in France and his displacement
from the United States.
All of this comes
to a head with his
experience of October 17th.
And he finally comes
to the conclusion that
it's time to leave Paris.
I wanted to observe also
that October 17th in,
within the context of a novel
that is largely realistic
and plausible, October
17th is the only actual
historical event that is mentioned
and narrated in great detail.
Indeed, we really feel
Gardner Smith's background
as a journalist coming
out in this passage.
It's deeply sort of invested
in a kind of documentary reportage.
He gives tons of evidence,
including place names
in Paris and, and sites of the violence.
And yet curiously, he gets the date wrong.
We don't know whether this
is intentional or, or a typo
but in fact, Gardner Smith
writes on October 1st, 1961
the Algerian National Liberation
Front called on Algerians
living in Paris to go into the streets
and hold a demonstration.
So there's something very curious
about the way in which he,
we think deliberately,
misrepresents the date.
And we can talk about that perhaps
in the Q and A a little bit.
I want to just say a few more things
about how "The Stone Face" functions
within the context of representation.
As Tyler mentioned this
was the very first novel
to narrativize the events of October 17th.
Interestingly, it's an American novel.
It would take until 1983 to see the first
French novel published that
represent these events.
This is a book called (speaking French),
or "Murder in Memoriam"
by Didier Daeninckx.
And then it would probably take,
in my estimation until 2005
before we get really this sort
of broader circulating
work, cultural work to
represent October 17th, then
that would be the film "Caché"
by the Australia Austrian
director, Michael Haneke
which came out in 2005.
And while it doesn't represent the events
in terms of, insofar, it doesn't reproduce
the repression and the massacre,
it does make interesting
sidelong reference to the events
of October 17th in a
way that really embodies
and crystallizes the way the
event itself has sort of lived
in the shadows of French history
and in the shadows of discourse.
So "The Stone Face," one of
the most interesting things
about it, I think, is the
way it so clearly testifies
to how visible the
violence would have been
in Paris on that Tuesday evening.
And indeed how threatening the spectacle
of Algerian political sovereignty
and subjectivity would have
been to the nation at the time.
It also gives a sense of how discourse
at the time was absolutely
crackling with race talk.
And this is something you
don't have to rely on the novel
for this, the novel does
a very good job of it,
but we can also confirm this
through contemporary materials
from the press and through
archival materials.
And this is important to underscore
because it allows us to
construct October 17th
also as a racially motivated episode
of state terror and police violence
which is extremely important
to ongoing conversations
about truth and reconciliation in France.
And it also makes "The
Stone Face" even moreso
a key text for comparative
transnational study.
I just wanted to end on, if I might,
on a quote from the novel towards the very
very end that I think
is incredibly prescient.
And so, as Simeon has announced
to his French friends that
he's going to be leaving,
one of his friends says to
him, don't go, you'll see.
As soon as the Algerian war is over
everything in France will be good again.
And to this Simeon replies, and I quote,
"It's a long time before
things will be good here again.
France really hasn't
even begun to suffer yet
from the things that
happened during this war."
And I think in the
context of a France where
we have recently seen
a report commissioned
by the president on how to
effect some kind of change
in Franco-Algeria relationships,
this is the Stora report.
I think we can read Simeon's comment
as indeed incredibly resonant to this day.
And so with that I'll invite Alice
and the rest of the panelists back
to the forum so that we can exchange about
this novel and its implications.
- Thank you so much.
All of you, you're so succinct
and you make me want to
ask so many questions.
I think I'd like to start
with Simeon, with Simeon
with the text, before we move into
the political and ethical issues.
First of all, why "The Stone Face."
What about that title
and how does it set up
the various premises of the novel?
- Well, oh, go ahead Adam.
- No, no, please.
- No, I was just, I was just going to say
I think "The Stone Face" is a symbol
of man's inhumanity to man.
I think there's also a
Sartrian in reference there,
but I'm not a literary scholar,
so I'm not sure, but
yeah, I mean, I think,
"The Stone Face," one of
the most arresting parts,
of descriptions of the novel,
and I think, again, something
that's historically based
in the description of October 17th,
is he he shows a policeman beating up
a woman and her child, right.
And just the idea that somebody
could do that, shows how
he, that shows they must
have a face made of stone,
it seems to me.
- I mean, he's
- He's in fact, working
on painting, he's painting
he's painting "The Stone
Face", which is a reference
to this experience that
he had, being brutalized.
In fact, one of his eyes
was, was gouged out,
there's a patch on his eye,
he was blind, half blinded by,
but in a racist attack back in the States.
- It made me think of watching the face
of Chauvin as the verdict
was announced with looking
at his eyes and trying to
find something in those eyes.
- Right, I mean, it functions
as this kind of recurring leitmotif
in the novel for the face of racism right.
He ascribes it first to the
young boy who, as Adam said
gouges out his eye,
later to a police officer
in Philadelphia who beats him senseless.
And with each of these events
of violent racism, he experiences, he says
that he sees, again, this
face, it's always the same face
"The Stone Face", the face of racism.
He sees this again in
the French police officer
who is beating the Algerian woman.
And as Adam also mentioned, he is
he's an amateur painter in the novel.
And so he's also trying
to paint "The Stone Face".
And interestingly, one of the, in fact,
the culminating paragraph of
the novel, has him slashing
up the canvas of the
painting of "The Stone Face"
as he has decided to return
to the United States,
bought his ticket, booked
passage, and is ready to go.
So there's a kind of, there's a certain
I hate to say there's a certain triteness
to the way this is handled in the book,
but that's also part of the
way in which he's tried to pull
through this thread of what the face
of racism looks like
and how he reacts to it.
- And that's what's kind of,
both dated and charming about novel.
It is quite a didactic fiction about this
(speaking French) this
growing awareness that he has
about the stone face, and the notion
that the stone face is the
same everywhere, which is
his realization towards
the end of the novel,
was in fact common to
depictions of October 17,
as Lia knows the, I remember
in the film by Panijel,
there are references
to the Holocaust in it,
- [Lia] That's right.
- Right, and of course
later on, we discover
in the late nineties
and at the time of the
of the Papon trial, that the Paris prefect
who was presiding over this massacre
was guilty not only of
war crimes in Algeria,
where he served as an official
and also during the Vichy
period of the deportations.
- That's right.
- That's the whole
multi-dimensional memory is
a multi-directional memory very much
in operation here, for sure.
In some ways it's a novel
about how you translate racism,
how he translates the racism of his youth
in his experience of
Paris and how different,
and yet how much the same.
Can you,
- What's interesting,
- Sorry, Lia, go ahead.
- No, I'm sorry, I was just going to say
it's just interesting to note that in two
out of these three cultural texts
from right after the October 17th massacre
we have these comparative gestures
with World War II and the Holocaust
not just in the documentary
is, as Adam mentioned
(speaking French) but
also in "The Stone Face"
and so far as Simeon is involved
with a woman who is a
survivor of the Holocaust
a Polish Jew, who has, whose
parents have been murdered
who herself was a victim
of sexual violence
at the hands of a Nazi officer.
And so again, this idea
that the comparison,
the comparative gestures, they're not just
in terms of a transnational
look across the Atlantic ocean
but also looking to the Holocaust as well.
- And there's an incredible scene where
an Algerian guy's expressing
his feelings of racist rage
about the Jews of Algeria,
who were collaborators
with the powers and so on.
And so no one is really
spared a guilty conscience
in this experience. (laughs)
- And Simeon himself, it
seems has participated
in something that is
described as not quite a rape
but like a rape, when he was a teenager
in a flashback.
- Yeah, you know, it's interesting
because that whole link
with the Holocaust,
World War II, also exists
in Murder in Memoriam, right?
And in some ways it sort
of flips the script because
with the Papon trial, it
starts with Papon being
on trial for his complicity
in the Holocaust.
And only then does it
emerge, the whole history
of October 17, in Murder
in Memoriam it's sort of
the reverse, where you first
see the October 17th massacre
and then gradually become aware
of his participation
in the Holocaust, yeah.
- Yeah, I remember Vergès
was trying to make hay
with that and make France
incapable of judging anybody
because of its own lack
of moral standards.
- Right.
- Very interesting.
Can we now skip to the end of the novel,
which has been much debated
and there's a very brilliant section.
And Lia talk about, about
the decision by Simeon
which is so different,
Simeon decides to return
to the U.S. and join the movement,
yet William Gardner Smith goes to Ghana
and this has occasioned a debate including
by Paul Gilroy, who thinks
that returning the United States
is something of a cop-out.
Lia, do you want to take that on?
It's such an interesting,
- Well, I can say it's, it's fascinating.
I mean, I'm not sure why
characters would have to
follow the trajectories of
their authors or vice versa.
My understanding though,
is that originally
Gardner Smith had written
the novel's ending
with Simeon staying in France
or perhaps going to Africa
but that it was at the
suggestion of his editor at
Farrar, Straus and
Giroux that he was highly
encouraged to return Simeon
to the United States.
So this might be one of
those instances where
the editorial hand weighed
heavier than what the author's
original desires or
intentions might have been.
But indeed Paul Gilroy has
criticized this ending.
He calls it a kind of capitulation
to narrow a demands of kinship.
And it's sort of interesting to see how
the trajectories of Simeon Brown
and William Gardner Smith are
then cleaved apart, right?
William Gardner Smith goes to Ghana
for a time, where he lives and is involved
with liberation struggles
and then eventually returns
to France where he lives
out the rest of his
unfortunately short life.
I think it's a little bit of a shame
to judge the return of
Simeon Brown so harshly.
I'm not sure exactly that it
capitulates to anything.
On the one hand, it separates Simeon Brown
from his compatriots,
the other black Americans
in exile in Paris, but it returns him
to his homeland to
participate in a struggle.
And I think William, it seems
that William Gardner Smith
what we know from his correspondence is
that the decision to stay,
the decision not to go back
to the United States, was
something that haunted him.
He wrote in letters to
his mother, for example,
that although he felt
comfortable in France
he also felt uncomfortable
because he couldn't be political.
He couldn't engage.
He was constantly reminded
that it wasn't his place to engage
in the political struggles in France.
And this does seem to have
been something that weighed
on his conscience quite a bit.
We also know that several
of his other works were
translated into French.
And the understanding is
that he never tried to have
"The Stone Face" translated
into French because he knew he was dealing
with a kind of political dynamite
and that it would just
get him into trouble.
- I just realized that
that was partly his desire,
because we've all wondered
why it hasn't been translated.
It's now in translation
at the (speaking French)
it's coming out in October,
- That's great news.
- next October.
So it will finally exist
in the French context.
It'll be very interesting
to follow the reviews.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah, I mean, one of the
things that interests me
about this question, Alice,
is that in some ways, the idea
that Simeon would return to
the United States is the most
fitting end to the novel,
the way it takes shape.
I mean, if you see the
novels as a repudiation
of the politics of exile
and an emphasis on the unity
of world struggles, well,
why shouldn't he go back
to the United States?
You know, why shouldn't he
go back to a place where
he can be politically active?
But the point is, as you
say that, first of all, he,
William Gardner Smith, the
author did not do that.
Many others did not do that as well.
I mean, all you have to do
is look at James Baldwin
who was one of the biggest critics
of people like Richard Wright.
Well, James Baldwin spent most of the rest
of his life in the French Riviera, right.
He went back to America from
time to time to give talks
and so on and so forth,
but he never went back
to become politically involved
permanently in America.
So, you know, it does say something about
the attraction of this
kind of experience, even
for those people that in many
ways reject it politically.
- Adam said something, yeah,
- He did, I mean, of course
a Baldwin did go back
at a critical juncture.
He went back in 1957 and
he writes about that sense
of survivor's guilt and
he felt moved to return,
particularly in "No Name in the Street."
I think Gilroy's essay is brilliant, but
I don't see how returning to
the States to become involved
in civil rights movement 19,
you know, in the early 1960s
in 1963, in 1961, this novel
could have been a capitulation.
And in fact, in this
novel, he says the reason
he's returning is to join
forces with America's Algerians.
The experience of exile
has nourished his thinking
and has allowed him to place
the black American experience
in a wider context of
anti-colonial liberation struggles,
but has widened his perspective.
And he feels the same desire,
I think, that leads his friend Akhmed,
a young Kabyle medical
student, to leave France
and to fight in the in
the mountains of Kabylia
with the FLN, so I think it is consistent.
At the same time, we do know
that originally Simeon Brown
decides to go to Africa.
In fact, there are
conversations in the novel
with African students,
none of whom is named,
why don't you come build an
independent African state
with us, you're needed there.
You'll be comfortable among your people.
- That's the kinship.
- But he doesn't go to Africa, of course.
I think that was in fact, a
request of his editor at FSG.
I don't see it as a capitulation.
I see, because he's going
under a very different,
a very different pretext, and
he's not simply going home.
He sees home in a different light.
- And not to belabor the point
but narratively it's
totally coherent, right?
I mean, we see Simeon
Brown sort of beginning to
imagine himself involved in
sort of analogous struggles.
I'm just going to quote,
"he imagined himself on an
Algerian mountain fighting
alongside Akhmed, then he imagined himself
in Angola fighting with the nationalists,
or in the Congo aiding
the imprisoned prime
minister Patrice Lumumba
Then he returned with ache to reality."
And there's also on the
micro level, the setup of the
the little girl in Arkansas
who he sees being prohibited
from going into the school.
And then the children he
sees, the Algerian children
he sees in the streets with
their mothers being threatened
by police and so on sort of
the micro narrative level.
And in terms of all the
parallelisms that have set up
it's coherent that that
Simeon would make this move.
- Yeah, you seem to be
implying that he actually
does learn something from this
transnational experience of racism.
It brings to mind a
passage that we've talked
about where Simeon is, I guess he's
on a bus and it's thinking of Harlem.
He's in Paris, and he thinks of Harlem.
We actually think, Sarah,
do you have the passage
so that you can share the screen?
Great, Adam, do you feel like reading?
- Sure, I can. "Northward toward Harlem.
The further north the bus moved,
the more drab became the
buildings, the streets
and the people, cheap stores
selling clothes, furniture,
kitchen utensils,
easy terms 10 months to pay.
Cafes became dimmer, the streets, narrower
and noisier, more and more
children filled the sidewalks.
Men out of work with nothing
to do and no place to go, stood
in sullen, futile groups
on street corners.
Arab music blared from the dark cafes
or from the open windows of bleak hotels.
Then suddenly, police were everywhere,
stalking the streets, eyes
moving insolently from face
to face, submachine guns
strung from their shoulders.
It was like Harlem, Simeon thought,
except that there were
fewer cops in Harlem
but maybe that too would come one day.
Like Harlem and like all
the ghettos of the world.
The men saw through the window
of the bus had whiter skins
and less frizzly hair, but they were
in other ways like the
Negroes in the United States.
They adopted the same
poses, stashing on corners
ready for and scared of
the ever possible trouble,
eyes solid and distrusting, dressed
in pegged pants, flashy shirts,
and narrow pointed shoes.
He could almost hear them
saying, whachu putting down, man,
just playing it cool,
just playing it cool, man,
trying to keep ole Charlie off my back.
Ole Charlie paced the street,
waving his submachine gun.
Street vendors shouted
their wares in Arabic,
fruit, clothes, vegetables.
He remembered the pushcarts in
his childhood on 10th street
the sweating men plugging
holes in watermelons
so you could taste them,
opening fish and cleaning them
and scaling them for you,
shouting in the mornings,
any old rags, any papers, any iron?
The odors of rotting food and
cooking mingled in the air
and he remembered how
they had smelled to him,
the fried chicken or the greens,
the uncollected garbage
and the alleys and gutters.
Arab music assailed them from all sides.
The Blues, where was the Blues Singer now?
In the dismal cafes, men played pinball
or football machines or stood at counters
staring at nothing, empty
cups in front of them.
There were no women.
The police paced the
streets, their faces hard."
- Thank you so much.
So in the hard faces
there's the leitmotif of
"The Stone Face", right?
It's one of the most written passages
I think in a novel that
uses dialogue, I think often
as a kind of paddle boat to
get somewhere in an argument.
I mean, it's very, very
literary and layered.
- And after that passage, he writes
that Simeon expected to
be seen as a brother.
But in fact, he's not, he's an outsider
and he's suspect, not just
because he's not Algerian
but also because he's American too.
- He has described this novel
as the novel of the guilty bystander.
You agree?
- Well, I was gonna mention the, one
of the other famous
passages in the book where
Simeon is walking past
a group of Algerians
and someone yells out,
"hey, how does it feel to be a white man?"
Of course, no Algerian in
Paris, would ever have said
that to an African American
in the 1960s, right?
This is not an Algerian speaking.
This is Simeon speaking,
conscience speaking.
(panelists laughing)
So, you know, in other words,
all of the freedom in Paris
that he's been luxuriating in,
is really not freedom at all.
It's really white privilege.
Okay, he doesn't use those words
but that that's clearly what it is.
And it's one of the first novels
I know that makes that point
so clearly in an international context.
- Wow, I mean, why don't we,
we're gonna switch to the
audience questions soon
but I want to ask you to end,
what does this novel
have to tell us today?
How does it fit into the current debate?
I think you addressed
some of those issues, Adam
in your preface about the current trouble
over identity politics
versus universalism.
What position does this novel take?
- Well, I, on the one hand
it's very much an anti-racist novel.
And on the other hand, it's
a rather subtle critique
of a politics based narrowly on identity.
As Tyler pointed out earlier,
even the notion of race is situational.
He is not black in the way
that he is black in America
once he is in Paris,
it's the Algerians who
occupy that position.
And he becomes aware, of course
that his black brothers so to speak,
the writers, the Cafe du Tournon circle,
have become quite complacent
about the privilege that
they are enjoying in Paris
and would prefer not to be associated
with this despised minority.
So in order to move into solidarity
with the Algerians, he has
to disaffiliate from people
around the Cafe du Tournon,
the black expatriates.
So to me, it's very much
a novel about the grounds,
the ethical grounds of
fraternity and solidarity,
and a critique of the notion
that race is a sufficient grounds
for that kind of solidarity.
It also places race in a much
more international context,
in a context of, in this
case of decolonization.
So in that sense, I think it's
refreshingly heterodox.
It cuts against, I think some of
the rigid, and essentialist thinking about
about identity that has
become, unfortunately,
I think a reflex in the
States in recent years.
- Yeah, Lia, I'm thinking
about all the work you've done
on the invisibility and
visibility, the 17th of October
and the way that he makes it visible,
versus the way that state violence
and police violence is visible today
and how that has changed.
- Oh, well, I mean, of
course I think, you know
one of the obvious things
is technology there.
We have this, we have
this fictionalized account
of William Gardner Smith in
the voice of Simeon Brown,
but obviously William Gardner
Smith witnessed what happened
on October 17th and
recounted it in this novel.
But we do know, and we
have now the evidence
that photographs were taken that night.
There's photographic documentary evidence
of the police violence.
If it had happened today,
we would have body cams.
We would have instant release
of this kind of footage.
These things would become memes,
they would be posted on social media.
Clearly in 1961, that's not an option.
And indeed the photographs that were taken
by journalists circulating
in Paris that night
were censored by the government.
So while some of them made their way
into the press before the
press was fully censored
most of them weren't seen
until decades after the events themselves.
So there's a certain interesting
way in which comparing
with today, you know,
technology makes things visible
in a way that it couldn't have in 1961.
- Despite that huge banner
across the Seine saying
they drown Algerians.
- Here they drown Algerians.
That's also a fantastic story
because numerous accusatory
graffiti were painted
along the Seine the
weeks after October 17th.
And yet they were, as soon
as they were discovered
they were guarded by the police,
so that people couldn't take
pictures of them ostensibly.
And we have one photograph
of one of these graffiti
that was taken by an amateur photographer
who happened to crop out,
when he took the photograph,
he happened to be able
to crop out the gendarmes
who were guarding the tag.
It's just an extraordinary
document that also
didn't see the light of
day until I think 1986
when Humanité published
its 25th anniversary
special coverage of October 17.
- I want to make another
point about October 17th
which at times is not addressed
but I'm going back to my
history, my own history
as a historian of the Paris
suburbs, because in many ways
October 17th is an invasion
of the city by the suburbs.
Of Algerian communities
and other communities living outside Paris
coming in and invading the heart
of the city and being destroyed precisely
because they are at a place
where they do not belong.
And this is all happening at a time when
both the independence of
Algeria and the reorganization
of the greater Paris area are
happening at the same time,
so in fact, the three new
departments that are created
outside Paris are given numbers
from the three former Algerian departments
once Algeria becomes independent, right?
So there's a sense of
wishing, you know, the
the Paris suburbs are the
new post-colonial France.
- Exactly, yeah, yeah.
- And you know and just to,
I want to just piggyback
on that point, Tyler, there
is a a major demonstration
that takes place in February of 1962,
but the demonstrators are,
- White.
- white French people
in the communist party
orbit at the Metro Charonne.
8 demonstrators are killed.
And that's what gets remembered.
It's the Charonne massacre,
it's not October 17.
- Right, right.
- It's interesting,
- Go head Lia.
- It's interesting just to
piggyback off both of those
if I might, it's true
that proportionally, most
of the Algerian demonstrators that came
into Paris that night
lived outside of Paris,
lived in the suburbs, lived in the
large slum that was Nanterre.
But significant numbers also lived
within the city limits,
but were invisible.
So the event is often
figured, when it was figured
in the press as a kind of,
invasion of the Capitol, right.
A taking of the capital from
forces coming from without,
Ignoring, in fact that
large numbers of Algerians
lived (speaking French),
within the city limits,
but weren't seen to the
public until they emerged
in this kind of spectacular
demonstration on October 17th.
- I mean, people that lived
in the (speaking French)
for example, on the top floors.
- Right, right, right.
Or, you know, five men to a bed.
- Now back in the days when Paris actually
had mixed classes because of them, but.
- Right, Right.
- Exactly.
- Listen we've got some
interesting questions
and a little bit of time.
Was Gardner Smith
influenced by Frantz Fanon
who like you, connected
as thinking about racism
and the black condition
to anti-colonial struggle?
And in particular, the
Algerian war of independence.
- You know it's interesting.
You will not find, even
in his work of reportage,
"Return to Black America"
which was published in,
I think 1970, and it's
a quite interesting book
a single reference to Fanon.
There's no reference to Fanon.
He, I mean, he might've been aware of,
he was certainly aware of
"The Wretched of the Earth"
and perhaps also "Black
Skin, White Masks."
"The Wretched of the Earth" was published
in December of 1961,
this novel appears in 63.
So likely he knew it.
There is a chapter in the book
where he meets two young Algerian women
who've been tortured back home.
And one of the women says
that because we've contributed
to the Algerian struggle, we
can now choose our own husbands
and we will never go
back to wearing the veil.
Now, of course, this is
a very, it turns out to
be a very optimistic understanding
of what's going to happen
in post independence Algeria,
but it's an account that exactly
mirrors Fanon's description
of Algerian women in year five
of the Algerian revolution
or a dying colonialism,
the essay Algeria Unveiled.
So my sense is that he probably
was familiar with Fanon
but there are no traces,
no explicit traces,
of Fanon in his work.
- Fanon didn't have a presence in Paris
in those years, right?
I mean, he was,
- No, no, when he left,
he left Paris and, sorry,
he left Leon in late 1953, returned very
very briefly on his way to Tunis
in late 1956 and never came back.
So no, but François Maspero,
the left wing publisher,
published (speaking French)
and then (speaking French).
So he did, he had a small
presence in an activist community
and people who were part of the
(speaking French) circle
the people who were
in the (speaking French) network
were aiding the Algerian rebels.
They knew about his work.
And in fact, there is a character
in "The Stone Face" named Henri,
a Frenchman who is the one
Frenchman who admits that
there is a problem with racism.
By the end of the novel, he's working
with the (speaking French),
the (speaking French) network.
- We have a question about
how much William Gardner's
life corresponded to the
life of Simeon in the novel.
I mean, things, I imagined the
question could involve things
like the relationship with Maria,
with a Jewish Holocaust survivor, or
- I think that, well,
there is a certain parallel
obviously, because he was a journalist,
he had been at the Pittsburgh Courier
he ended up working with AFP.
I don't know that he painted,
there's some indication
if you read Hazel Rowley's
biography of Richard Wright
that Maria, the Polish
Jewish survivor, is based on
an Ashkenazi Jewish woman
who had been a lover
of Richard Wright, and Gardner Smith ended
up kind of stealing her
from Richard Wright.
But I don't know,
but otherwise their
stories very much diverge.
Gardner Smith was married three times.
I think the parallels are
rather superficial in the end.
- Yeah, here's an interesting question,
bringing in yet another identity group.
Was Smith in any way aware of
the Pied-Noir born in Algeria?
For example, Camus.
Estrangement was part of the
identity of the Pied-Noir.
Do you think that estrangement
can be a concept linked
with a kind of feeling
that goes on with racism?
Complex question.
- Well the Pied-Noir were
not Pied-Noir in 1971,
they only became Pied-Noir
when they were quote unquote,
"repatriated" to France.
That's when the term emerges.
There is a reference
toward the end of the novel
to French soldiers
returning home and to groups
like the OAS forming, which
were composed obviously,
comprised obviously of ultra Pied-Noirs.
But I don't think that he really,
certainly he would have
read Camus, no one,
no writer was unfamiliar
with Camus' works.
But I think the politics,
the political vision
that's espoused here
has very little to do,
and in fact is almost
antithetical to Camus' vision.
- Here's another complicated question.
Why would the protagonist
want to exchange one place
of racism for another?
It seems to me that the American
experience can be no place
of exchange, especially
given the legal racism
that he would have met upon his return.
- Well, let me respond to that,
with a bit of an anecdote.
One of the people I interviewed
for my book "Paris Noir"
was a woman who had been,
she was a black woman
who been a student in
Paris in the early 1960s.
And she talked about how black students
from America at that
time would come to Paris
and meet with Richard Wright
and meet with all these people.
But she said there was a
difference because rather
than having the idea that they
was going to sit at the feet
of Richard Wright and learn
wisdom and create literature
and all that, they would come
and challenge him and say
why aren't you back in the United States?
What are you doing here?
Why aren't you a part of the
struggle basically, right?
And so I think this novel
sort of reflects that, that
in effect, people had a duty
to be a part of that struggle.
You know, this is 1961, 1962
the freedom rides are
taking place in the South.
For example, there's all sorts
of violent incidents going on.
People are literally putting
their lives on the line.
And there's this idea that,
you do not have the right to, sit here
in Paris in comfort and talk
about how terrible things are.
- I mean, even Angela
Davis, it's very clear she's
in Frankfurt studying with Adorno.
It's very clear she's eager to get back.
That's a little later, right?
Feel the same urge.
Here's a great question.
Which could be our last one.
So what, what do you guys
think are the textual
and political stakes of
this forthcoming translation
of "The Stone Face" into
French, thinking, for instance
of how it would interact
with the Stora report
which mentions the role of
re-additions and translations,
and the current discussions
of race in France,
which tend to dismiss
intersectionality and positionality
as symptoms of the Americanization
of French public debate.
And we have one minute. (laughs)
- Macron would say, it's
the very first example
of woke culture from America
invading France, right.
- Except I can't think
of a less woke book.
- Not woke, yeah.
- I think it's going to go,
I mean, I hope it goes off like something
of a bomb, with no victims.
Obviously it's an important book.
I think it's going to be disturbing.
I think, going back to something Adam said
the question of how
anti-essentialist this book is,
that's one of the big
lessons to take away.
And I would hope somehow that
would also inform the debate
because I would hate to see it reduced
to a kind of a centralist debate such
as what do Americans
know about, et cetera.
But I think, to answer John's question
I think the stakes are high.
I hope it will have the visibility.
I hope the translation
will get the visibility
in France for the stakes to play out.
As I mentioned, I think
in the context of the (speaking French)
it's very interesting to have this account
come to light in France right now.
- Invitation to write a critical essay
in French on the book.
(panelists laughing)
That's a wonderful place to stop.
I thank you so much for being here
and for lending your
expertise to the celebration.
- Thank you so much, Alice.
- Thank you.